[Musique]
bel album que j'ai jamais fait ouais
j'en suis persuadé vrai ouais c'est à
lui à un moment où effectivement je
venais un petit peu du punk et à et
c'était important pour moi enfin j'étais
dans je voulais un petit peu ce qu'est
les choses comme ça maintenant sujet
passé ça et je faire des belles chansons
et j'ai fait ce que je voulais et je
continue à faire ce que je voulais et on
verra plus tard mais pour le moment
c'est parfait quoi le problème avec vous
je pense c'est que à l'époque vous avez
un énorme succès avec taxi girl qui
était un groupe un peu sainte et
kraftwerk un comme ça un peu électro pop
quoi alors alors que vous en faites vous
êtes un vrai rock'n'roll heroes avec ce
que ça comporte de taille adage de
vaines
objection d'héroïne oui ouais un peu
comme il dit popp disons le succès que
vous avez eue c'est avec un groupe un
peu clean c'était un malentendu lui même
et je les accepte complètement dans ce
que je voulais dire ok alors voilà vous
étiez au sommet avec taxi girl
et puis votre rencontre avec l'héroïne
s'est passé un petit peu comme dans un
comme dans un film quoi vous êtes
backstage rose bonbon la fameuse boîte
de l'époque
et puis un jour il ya un mec qui arrive
comme ça et qui vous dit quelqu'un de
quelque chose ouais ouais moi je moi je
suis vraiment j'ai appris récemment je
pensais être timide mais on a dit
récemment que j'étais fabrique sociale
donc ça m'aidait parce que les
interviews tout ça je pouvais pas
répondre
j'étais complètement bloquer quoi et
puis et puis je me souviens très bien on
m'a mis une aiguille dans le bras
j'étais en train de vomir a déjà je me
suis dit ça y est j'ai trouvé avec j'ai
trouvé ma raison de vivre
voilà donc il a fallu du temps après
pour que je comprenne que
il n'y avait pas que ça et puis et puis
comme on était vachement plus fort que
ça est bon plein de choses en plus le
première fois c'est gratuit donc la
première phase est construit est bon et
la fameuse une lune de miel
c'est génial je tiendrai c'est évident
que personne ne prendrait de l'héroïne
si c'était mauvais mais comme je dis
toujours au dessus on en prend pour être
bien apprendre en prendre ou pas il
pourra être mal bien sûr pour vous ça
dure et 15 ans comme l'histoire way une
quinzaine de la neva épigraphe à 5
grammes par jour c'est beaucoup quand
même gouès way cinq membres plus ouais
ouais ouais ouais c'était beaucoup
c'est et des gens tour de guillaume
depardieu qui a fait 6 9 heures dos
moi j'ai dû faire ça en six mois quoi
enfin j'ai fait vingt verdoso - l'euro
chipote je compte plus c'est qu'on aime
on compte tu sais pas ce que c'est mr
pour vous en sortir la mère m'a
vachement il dit en parlant de ça
d'ailleurs quand on a une overdose c'est
pas du tout le white flash dont on parle
dans son canal c'est une claque de
pompiers dans la gueule c'est pas si
drôle que ça finalement
ouais c c c c c'est horrible c'est
horrible un verre d'eau ce vraiment
c'est tout c'est dégueulasse non rien de
bon là dedans c'est ce qui a détruit
taxi girl parce que déjà pierre wolson
bas il en est mort lui il est mort d'une
overdose
et puis d autres lance stéphane ils sont
partis à cause de ça stefana le bassiste
a
alors pris des études de maintenant les
astronomes et laurent ouailles
bien sûr il est parti au vietnam pour
décrocher mais bon c'est pas le meilleur
endroit c'est peut-être pas mais à la
fin vous vous retrouvez à 2,3 avec new
wave et c'est à mon avis c'est ce qu'on
a fait de mieux
enfin la musique allemand quand il y
avait juste l'ignorer c'est moi c'est se
croient que c'est vraiment un
c'était ce qui avait mis un album énorme
produit avec burnel qui s'appelle
seppuku qui sait tout coup
voilà un album génial merveille s'il
s'en est sorti alors lui
extraordinairement bien puisque
maintenant il fait toutes les chansons
de madonna
ouais il produit il fait les chansons de
ma nana mais il lemire est complètement
parce qu'il s'est enfermé dans un studio
pendant cinq ans dix heures par jour et
travaillait je trouve ça génial quand je
suis très content alors par votre mère
qu'est ce qui vous a permis de vous en
sortir de la dope
moi je voudrais pas qu'on puisse arrêter
la dope pour quelqu'un d'autre pour même
si c'est la femme qu'on aime ou quoi que
ce soit ce soit ici c'est pas ça c'est
les comics à la rade parce qu'on se rend
compte qu'on moi moi moi moi mon truc
depuis le début c'est quand même écrire
et je pouvais plus écrire plus rien ça
me dit ça m'a sûrement aidé à écrire des
trucs dans 99% des cas où jeter dans ce
que vous avez écrit la veille jésus vous
a aidé dieu m'a aidé à le faire mais
c'est parfois la tête directement aigle
au pearl away with it le christianisme
et le rock'n'roll sont les dernières
forme d'honnêteté
ouah je pense je le pense sincèrement
alors au départ vous êtes juif par votre
père catholique par bodmer déjà pas
facile alors pendant la guerre votre
grand mère paternelle
madame rose ou mais morte à auschwitz la
bella margoline ouais je suis arrêté à
dachau ensuite l'hôte ware est obligée
de se cacher évidemment en normandie
ouais mon grand père ancien la
libération votre mère a été poursuivi
pour intelligence avec l'ennemi en fait
elle est tombée amoureuse d'un médecin
de la wehrmacht qui était pas du tout
nazis qui étaient là qui était en france
qui étaient obligés parce que son ca
d'ailleurs il a fini en sibérie parce
qu'ils l'étaient pas ils étaient pas
nazi et voilà elle est tombée amoureuse
alors on peut prendre arletty 1 l'aurait
français mais mon cul internationale et
puis elle était vraiment heureuse quoi
alors
récemment à la télévision on avait eu
guy bop dire qu'il aimerait bien
retrouver une femme et faire un enfant
et vous moi aussi
après si j'ai bien sûr bien sûr mais je
sais pas si c'est possible ou encore
parce que voilà j'ai 44 ans j'ai je peux
faire peur peut-être mais bien sûr bien
sûr je rêve de ça ouais ouais je suis
way sur son rêve de ça donc tout ça
maintenant et terminé tu es un mec bien
je sais pas je suis pas si c'est un mec
bien j'essaye d'être un mec bien
[Musique]
daniel darc est ce que vous allez
régulièrement à l'église
j'ai au temple ouais ouais 18 rue du
faubourg du 3 mars
oui est ce que vous faites des
accompagnements de gens malades
j'ai fait pendant pendant presque deux
ans mais j'ai des personnes en fin de
vie
est ce que vous êtes inscrits sur les
listes électorales je devrais dire oui
non parce que vous reboucher les tubes
de dentifrice j'ai toujours fait ça
quand j'étais un mec même dans la pire
zhang tao boucher même si je crois way
d'affaires dont je ne serai pas de
motifs risque puisque vous regardez le
journal de 20 heures sur tf1
non non est-ce que marilyn manson vous
fait peur non j'ai peur pour lui je
pense qu'ils qui n'est en train
sincèrement
je pense qu'ils se trompent complètement
et qui joue avec des choses qui
contrôlent pas il se rend pas compte de
ce qui fait laurier saint pas non ouais
elle est pas méchante
c'est sympa julien lepers oscille sympa
on n'est pas méchants mais pas méchant
donc lui il est très bien
finalement les radars ça peut économiser
d'évidence pas mal ouais c'est très bien
pour la lessive tu sais pas le blanc est
la couleur je mélange un peu tout et
amer j'ai pas beaucoup de blancs n'ont
plus honte est un mec bien maintenant
mais c'est quoi un mec bien j'essaie je
te dis j'essaye de ceux ci ne pas faire
de mal voilà est-ce que c'est ça être un
mec bien presser le pas fan
[Musique]